how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we're going
to be talking about a subject that is
kind of sensitive right now to mcu fans
and that is black widow coming out
on video on demand on disney plus we got
a lot of information over the weekend a
lot of reports about disney plus and
whether or not black widow is in fact
going to go to the theaters or go
straight to video on demand on disney
plus
and there's a lot that you need to know
about whether or not this is actually
going to happen
or not including some things that disney
said over the weekend but don't worry in
this video i'm going to break down
everything that you need to know on
whether or not black widow is going to
video on demand or not
but first big congratulations to youtube
user
zv feinberg for being the winner of last
week's
mysterio funko pop just email me in the
email in my description and we'll get
you your prize and for this week's
giveaway
i'm giving away a dr strange funko pop
all you have to do to enter is be
subscribed to my channel
like this video and leave a comment on
the video down below i'll be picking a
winner next monday
so to start off i'm actually one of the
people who would like to see black widow
in the theaters now if theaters don't
open back up and it's a big safety
problem i understand to go into video on
demand and i'll be okay with it but i
would prefer to see it in the theaters
but here's the reality of the situation
there is absolutely
100 a chance that black widow could go
straight to video on demand on disney
plus for
29.99 a few days ago disney in their
earnings report
announced what disney plus is calling
premier access
now premiere access all that is is video
on demand
and with their announcement of their
premiere access they announced the first
movie going to the platform and that is
mulan mulan was a very big project for
disney and a very anticipated film and
was supposed to be a very big film in
the theaters
a lot of people were really looking
forward to it but now it is going
straight to video on demand on disney
plus
so here's how this works because there
seems to be some confusion about this
and here's how it will work for black
widow when they release the movie you
can buy it on premiere access for
29.99 but this is not a one-time watch
you own the movie on your disney plus
account and disney further explained
this
and this is how it will work for black
widow so i'll replace the word mulan
with black widow
once you have premier access to black
widow you can watch the film as many
times as you want on any platform where
disney plus is available
your access to mulan will continue as
long as you are an active disney plus
subscriber
so there you have it if black widow
comes out on video on demand on premiere
access
then as long as you're a disney plus
subscriber and you buy the movie you
will have it forever but of course the
big question is
is black widow coming out on premiere
access and right now the answer is
probably not a guaranteed yes but it
probably is going to come out on disney
plus premier access
and here's the reason why disney didn't
just make premiere access
only for mulan this is a business model
for disney plus to introduce
movies straight to video on demand
rather than theaters now obviously films
would make
more money if they were in theaters but
disney has a plan they specifically said
that they're going to watch mulan and if
it does well consider doing it for other
movies however we have learned some new
information over the weekend and it
seems like disney has already begun to
prepare for
other movies to be released over the
weekend the guys at murphy's
multiverse.com have discovered that
disney actually has plans to release
more films on disney's premiere access
soon while asking customer service about
mulan and other things coming to
premiere access here's what they had to
say
the disney rep said as per checking in
our data that the 29.99 is on top of
your yearly subscription
and your premier access for now we have
the mulan but
when the time goes by the premiere
access will be more updated and more
movies to watch
they went on to ask more questions and
the rep said as of now there is no
announcement yet for the list of movies
but
we guarantee you that disney plus will
offer you
more amazing movies so somebody at
disney plus in customer service
said that more movies are going to be
coming to premiere access
so clearly this is not just a one-time
thing with mulan
disney has plans to make this a full
service meaning
disney is 100 considering releasing
black widow on premiere access on disney
plus
and here's how they'll make their
decision right now the reopening for
major movie theater chains have been
pushed back and been pushed back over
and over again
and right now we basically have about
three months until black widow is
supposed to be released in theaters
now if we go another couple of months
and the theaters are not opened yet they
will push black
widow back again because disney won't
want black widow to be one of the first
films to premiere when the theaters
first
open they're going to want the theater
to be open for a little bit because when
they reopen a lot of people probably
aren't going to go at first even to see
black widow
they'd make a lot more money if they
actually put it on premier access
so if they push back black widow again
one more time
and theaters aren't expected to open
until next
year middle of next year they will most
likely make the decision to put black
widow on premier access on disney plus
because we love disney and we love
marvel but they are companies and they
need to make money and right now they
are losing a ton of money by just
sitting on black widow and if theaters
aren't going to open until another year
they will definitely
put black widow on premiere access this
way people can buy the movie
and not to mention they'll get money for
people signing up for disney plus
just to buy the movie and then of course
all the merchandising that comes with
that and right now disney is really
struggling with their parks being closed
for the most part and no movies coming
out so it really all comes down to when
the theaters are reopening and right now
it's said that they're not going to be
opening up again until middle of next
year meaning
the possibilities for black widow coming
out on premiere access
on disney plus are very very high so
stay tuned because the closer we get to
black widow's release date the more
we're going to know about it going to
theaters or
premiere access but again down below let
me know what you think about this would
you rather it go into theaters or would
you rather it go to premiere access if
theaters open this year
will you be going to see the film let me
know what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and instagram and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof